well the Las Vegas National Horse Show
is back at the South Point this week
bringing the world's best show jumping
to the heart of the valley here to talk
to us more about it this morning is
Hillary ridland she's a writer and a
trainer from California good morning
Hillary thanks so much for joining us
good morning good morning
um for those for those who aren't
familiar with show jumping and horses
it's such an amazing art form tell us
about the vent the event and returning
Champions who are here in town this year
oh gosh well there's all sorts of events
going on but the the major events that
we're leading up to in the South Point
Arena here is the World Cup qualifier
and that will go Saturday evening and
writers will accrue points to ride in
the final which I believe is in Omaha
Nebraska this year in April
what is it about horse jumping I mean it
looks incredibly hard but the the Rider
and the horse really have to be a tight
team don't they they have to be like one
together to ride and jump those rails
when you think about it it's it's a
sport in the Olympics it's a sport in
general where it's two athletes having
to refine their dance if you will to
Perfection so that every course they uh
the jump is Flawless and there are no
two courses that are the same so you
can't practice
a course
before an event
oh okay bring it all together
so you have to practice the discipline
and the Art of jumping and you just have
to be prepared for anything that's out
there that's amazing
um it's free for it's free admission and
what else is there for audiences to
enjoy and spectators
oh my gosh well there's the show jumping
we have face painting I think we have an
acrobat up on the main Concourse and we
have additional events going on in the
preferred Arenas which are are riders
that are working up to this level that
you'll see in the South Point Arena
they're in the beginning stages of
working with their horse and trying to
be the best wow well it looks very
exciting thank you Hillary for joining
us this morning and have a great weekend
and hope the event is wonderful for all
the the participants and Spectators
enjoy it maybe we get some new folks too
that'll come enjoy the sport thanks for
being with us that would be great thank
you very much nice to meet you